[Music]
andrew yang ran for president last cycle
he's now running for the mayor of new
york to replace bill de blasio yang is a
very smart guy who in the past year or
so has embraced the dumbest kind of
lifestyle liberalism really beneath him
and we've smacked him for it repeatedly
on the show because it's disappointing
to see it
but we want to be honest about andrew
yang when he says something really smart
we want to highlight it and he said
something very smart the other night
at the primary debate in new york here
he is
watch this the fact is mentally ill
homeless men are changing the character
of our neighborhoods
uh a woman my wife ellen is friends with
in her mom group in hell's kitchen was
punched in the face by a mentally ill
man
sent a picture of a bruised face around
the mom group spread like wildfire
this is happening in new york city and
we're not talking enough about it
families are leaving as a result in east
harlem the neighborhood has been changed
upper west side the neighborhood has
been changed
we owe our people and our families
better than this and i'm frustrated by
the political
nature of these responses i mean we're
not talking about
housing affordability we're talking
about the hundreds of mentally ill
people we all see around us every day on
the streets and the subways we need to
get them
off of our streets and our subways into
a better environment and when you ask
what i'm going to do differently i'm
going to
rebuild the stock of psych beds
in our city there will be no recovery
until we resolve this i will fix this in
new york
there will be no recovery until we
resolve this that is true not just of
new york but of the entire country if
you allow the mentally ill to live in
your parks or on your subways on the
sidewalk in front of your house
it's on you it's cruel and it's the
beginning of the end of civilization you
can't allow that
they deserve better and more important
the rest of us deserve better good for
andrew yang for saying that hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else